but littell good morning thanks for
joining us here on c-span morning to you
pleasure to be here the book is called
the company a novel of the CIA why did
you write it haha that's a very good
question you got me right on the spot I
make my living writing books this is my
13th published novel but I wrote this
particular one because of a longstanding
fascination with the subject matter
which is the Cold War and the Cold War
from the point of view of the Central
Intelligence Agency I've been sort of
nibbling around the edges of this book I
guess in many other of my books of my 13
novels about half of them are espionage
novels but they're all cold war stories
and so I always felt I was nibbling
around the edges of the big book and
this is the big book it meant to detail
with somebody who obviously knows a
thing or two about the inner workings of
the CIA how did you do your research a
lot of people think that I must have
been a member of the CIA or the KGB I
was a member of neither my research
actually took me a full year the first
year of work was nothing but reading
reading reading and making notes and the
big problems that kind of reading is to
organize your material so you can get
the details back when you need them so
the way I did it was I just read and
read and read there's a vast amount of
information out there in book form
article form and I also traveled to the
places I was writing about I went to
Moscow I went to Budapest I went to
Berlin I went to Pakistan in Budapest I
found the gentleman but one of my
sections deals with the Hungarian
Revolution of 1956
I found a gentleman who had participated
in it and he walked me through for two
days all the battle sites and all the
scenes and it was very moving very
interesting to see I mean that's how he
did my research and what did you learn
about Budapest or about the CIA in
general the CIA what I learned about the
CIA was his successes in his failures
this this organization especially in the
early 50s was really on the ramp I think
very courageous people on the ramp
of the Cold War and people forget how
dangerous the Cold War was in the early
50s the book starts out in Berlin when
it was a real killing field when the
Soviets were about a football field away
and we all thought that the the Soviet
Army would roll over Berlin to the
English Channel any at any given day the
CIA people used to keep thermite bombs
on their desks and on their safes to
destroy their secrets they figured they
had ten minutes to get out if the if the
balloon went up is they used to say so I
mean I learned about their successes I
learned about their failures but don't
forget this is fiction and I invented
successes and I invented Phillies try to
incorporate this into at least one of
the headlines from this morning's New
York Times which takes a look at
government agencies overall and how they
have reacted since September 11th to
terrorism and specifically Philip
Shannon writes about the the way these
agencies are collaborating or sharing
information or not doing so the CIA is
mentioned in all of this when you look
at a government bureaucracy like this
how does it all work how does it all
come together I think you put it you
think I didn't read the story but I saw
the headline you're putting your finger
on one of the great problems that led to
11 September which was the lack of
coordination between the various
intelligence agencies and establishments
in Washington in America curiously the
director of Central Intelligence is
supposed to direct all the American
intelligence operations but in practice
he'd ever really did and we're now
learning about for example about that
FBI memo that was that came out of
Phoenix in which an FBI agent drew
attention to the large number of Arab
men who were taking flight training that
memo never made it to another person who
might have had another detail I mean
it's all a puzzle and to put the pieces
of the puzzle together and a
coordination between the different
agencies is a huge problem Homeland
Security Director Tom Ridge is expected
on July 1st to unveil to the president
his recommendations for changes when it
comes to homeland security do you have
an opinion on what you think he should
include in that memorandum I think
I think the first thing that has to be
done there's no question that 11
September must be seen as one of the
great intelligence failures of American
history it's right up there with Pearl
Harbor it's right up there with the Bay
of Pigs and the interesting thing about
those two events was they were both
followed they were both followed by
commissions independent and very high
powered commissions which examined where
America went wrong there was no CIA at
the time of Pearl Harbor but these
Commission's examine the problem and the
the the the idea being that we should
make sure America doesn't go wrong in
the same way again now what I've noticed
is that since 11 September nobody nobody
has been studying the CIA presumably the
CIA is studying itself but can the CIA
examine itself I doubt it very much I
doubt whether any organization can
investigate itself Congress is just
beginning to scratch the surface and we
learned last week when they let go their
chief investigator that he was former
CIA yeah you know we have to start now
with a with a high-powered independent
investigative body that can look at the
American intelligence establishment and
see where it went wrong I mean in 1991
when the Soviet Union disintegrated when
the Berlin Wall came down America and
the in general and the intelligence
organizations in particular they lost
their enemy it seems to me that the
adrenaline stopped flowing that they
stopped they got out of the business of
taking risks they got out of the
business of telling people in Washington
things they didn't want to hear shops
will close down shops I mean stations
all over the world CIA operatives were
retired out in droves to the point where
we can read now with to the point where
there were no linguist capable of
debriefing Taliban defectors or even
more ironic when the CIA had Taliban
intercepts from these cellphone as they
use there was nobody in the CIA who
could translate them and they shopped
him out to the Pakistani secret service
is ironic because the Pakistani Secret
Service created the Taliban and they
were the stepchild of the Pakistani
Steel Secret Service which of course for
its own strategic reasons wanted to ring
India with Islamic states so I mean we
need to now step back and take a look at
the mindset of the CIA and the other
intelligence establishment and where
they were wrong and then set it right
our conversation is with Robert littell
he has written more than a dozen novels
including one of his most recent ones
the company a look at the CIA our phone
lines are open we'll get to your calls
in just a moment or you can email us at
journal at c-span org we spent about
three hours with Tom Clancy a couple
months ago and he said as a fiction
writer in his wildest imagination he
never could have envisioned the events
of September 11th is that one of the
reasons why we didn't anticipate it you
said earlier it was a communications
breakdown I you know America America's
security was so lacks airport security
and now we read about reservoir security
and we're worried now about trucks
coming into the cities nobody's got a
handle on this yet I thought that in
with hindsight that what the CIA should
have done before 11 September was
gathered together Clancy and some of the
other more imaginative writers around a
table like this and say how would you
attack America if you if you were
Islamic fundamentalist and you wanted to
do wanted to hurt America that might
have come up with a with an answer
Madison Wisconsin good morning our first
call for mister littell good morning
gentlemen I served on the border there
in the Fulda gap and I was there on the
border I will fix the audio if we could
go ahead caller we're you know I was
just saying that I was a soldier on the
Fulda gap when the walls out there and
I'm very fascinated with the whole
aspect on the Cold War and a lot of the
lore and legend that soldiers heard
about when we're there and I was just
wondering if mr. little could share a
couple of those story
with us this morning about the wool
coming down about things of operations
that the CIA had like we heard about
caches a weapon oh sure sure there was
some great there was some great
classical and legendary CIA operations
in the early days of the Cold War
you probably remember some of them you
remember when they dug a tunnel under
Berlin from the American sector to the
Soviet sector and for 18 months they
were tapping into the Soviet phone lines
and getting tons of information from
that the u2 was another enormous success
remember the u2 operation and that was a
CIA operation because they gave the ball
to the CIA because the Air Force would
have taken eight years to get the plane
off the ground think the CIA did it in
18 months something like that and they
were getting an enormous amount of
information on Soviet capabilities and
Soviet distribution of forces and that
kind of thing the stories of spying
across the Berlin Wall my fiction I
invent stories like that about defectors
and and that you know the story of
Volkov the famous Soviet defective
Volkov who turned up in Istanbul in the
early days of the Cold War he was a
diplomat but he was KGB and he he got in
touch with a with a British diplomat and
said I wanted the effect with my family
I have a lot of information including
information that can lead you to
identify a Soviet a Soviet mole inside
mi6 which was a British secret service
this information
he said don't radio it back because
we're monitoring your radio send it back
by pouch this information was sent back
to London by pouch and wound up on the
desk of Ken Philby who was the man in
charge of anti Soviet operations the man
in charge of anti Soviet operations for
mi6 was a soviet mole Philby went to his
boss and said this is so important that
I should go out there myself and get the
defector myself he took three days to
get there and of course by the timing
got there for mr. Volkoff and his family
no longer were around they had been
carried off back to Russia and
disappeared spies doors they go on and
on and they're great the company a novel
of the CIA by overlooked pres Robert
littell is the author
this is his 13th book our next call is
London England go ahead please
good afternoon I've traveled around
Eastern Europe Afghanistan place like
that and in the 70s I noticed the CIA
all over Afghanistan I think Europeans
see it a totally different way we never
saw Russia as a friend when the
Americans and the Russians joined up in
space the Russian satellite had to fly
eighth-highest and the American at its
lowest because they were so backward we
always knew they were back but we
wouldn't win a cell friend we felt more
threatened by America's invasions of
Russian territory we thought that would
lead to a war I mean like I said in
Afghanistan all over Europe Turkey and
Iran you saw these white Americans who
said they were working for the Peace
Corps but ever a bit to vote and the CIA
they've got everything from three years
and I think they've invaded virtually
every country and America the reason why
a lot of people don't like America is I
don't think he can name a single country
that America hasn't been to war with it
went to Libya 200 years ago it was a war
with Libya we seemed traded every
country in Europe including Britain
France Germany Italy Spain you name it
it just goes amnon and the CIA seems to
be the most incompetent I don't know
where they get their recruits from well
if you think America is the enemy I
think you got it completely backward
you're forgetting you're forgetting the
Cold War and you're forgetting the
threat from from the Soviet Union and
you're forgetting even in Berlin in the
1950s the Soviet troops and the Soviet
armaments outnumbered the three allies
combined and there were there were many
people a minute many
military thinkers who thought that the
Soviet Union could want it to go across
Europe up to the English Channel and
that if they if they wanted to that
Stalin don't forget until 1953 they
couldn't do it in six weeks you know if
you're looking at the CIA and America is
their enemy you have it really backwards
let's not forget who liberated Europe in
World War two let's not forget the
Marshall Plan let's not forget the
American aid all over the world that's
not to say that the CIA didn't didn't
have big boondoggles what's a call when
you make a mistake in him in English I
think boondocks was a good word over the
years I mean I'm prepared to go along
with you in terms of Budapest for
example I'll give you two examples the
guy who was the man who was the deputy
director of plans at the time his name
was Weisner wasn't satisfied with the
idea of being a rampart against the
Soviet Union he wanted a roll back
communism and America was doing under
under this deputy director plans of the
CIA was doing what it could to roll back
communism and to liberate the slave
states don't forget they were slave
states I've been to Bulgaria many times
curiously over the years and all the
other East European countries I visited
them all and I visit visited the Soviet
Union many times and they were under a
dominated by a terrible system so
Weisner decided to roll about communism
I go back to Budapest when finally after
being invited to rise up one people did
which was the the freedom fighters in
Hungary America just left them out on
the line to dry President Eisenhower and
and his Secretary of State Dulles
decided that the United States wasn't
going to risk World War three for for
some rebels fighting for their own
liberation in Budapest and in Hungary so
that was one great error and the second
that comes to mind immediately I do a
whole section on Budapest and then I do
another whole part on on the Bay of Pigs
the Bay of Pigs is humble
able to read into it now 40 years later
you you are hard put to understand how
it was so dumb how they could launch an
operation that was so that had such a
small chance of success let's not forget
they were landing 1600 Cuban Patriots on
a remote beach surrounded by a swamp and
these people were supposed to defeat
Castro's army of 200,000 men I think the
big mystery which I addressed in my
fictional way is why Kennedy who was
supposed to be a smart cookie and why
the people around Kennedy who was
supposed to be smart
signed off on this and that had to do
with his relationship with Judith Exner
who wrote a book about this by the way
before she died about the fact that she
was sharing a bed with the President of
the United States and also with Giancana
who was the mafia chief of Chicago but
this is all but you think that list of
the Bay of Pigs I think that's why
Kennedy signed off on the day of Pigs I
think that's why he gave him the
go-ahead to try to do what they were
doing because I think he was convinced
that that the CIA was trying to
assassinate Castro through the Mafia and
I think he had inside information that
they were going to do it and it didn't
do it
Chicago Democrats lying good morning
good morning I have a couple of things
I was watching Fox News Fox cable news
and they said that the reason that the
United States was looking for Osama bin
Laden is because that they got a report
from Yemen that Osama bin Laden and
other had met in Yemen and that was the
reason that they thought Osama bin Laden
had something to do with the world
tracing bombers then Yemen said that
they never said that and they were
supposed to retract the statement and
then they said Osama bin Laden had
nothing to do with the world's training
centers so I'm wondering why they are
still bombing then scan Afghanistan and
steal killing the people over there and
then second thing I heard like when
they're going to sue Sudan and
Afghanistan can fight that the majority
of these soldiers are that they're
fighting our children between the ages
of 8 and 12 can you give me some insight
on that well I think the first thing I
care to say is that today it's an open
and closed case about Osama bin bin
Laden's responsibilities in the World
Trade Center attack simply there's a
smoking gun look at the tapes the clips
in which he talks about it and admits it
so if you think that he's not
responsible you have to go back and take
a look at these news clips that
everybody's seen and there's no doubt
about that the interesting thing about
bin Laden is he's been around a long
time I handed this book in to my
publisher who is Peter Mayer of overlook
press one year in one week before 11
September and I have Osama bin Laden as
a character in the book in this section
on Afghanistan and I have so I mean I
was already interested in the problem
and the problem was that America America
seemed to be creating its own enemy by
arming and encouraging the Mujahideen
the way we did without reservations we
were we were preparing and arming the
people who would attack us next they
made no bones about the fact I'm talking
about the fundamentalist that when they
got rid of the Soviet Union from
Afghanistan we were the next on their
list we were the next target and America
has this short side forever has this
short-sighted during the Cold War it's
short-sighted anti-communism which was
anything that was anti Soviet we were
four and Afghanistan in those days I'm
talking about the the war this is before
the Taliban the war against the Russian
forces when they occupied Afghanistan
that was I think a President Reagan and
Casey who was the head of the the
director of the CIA saw this as payback
time for Vietnam Vietnam the Russians
supported the people we were fighting
in in Vietnam 55,000 or more American
soldiers were killed 900 and more than
900 planes were shut out by Russian
missiles and I think they saw the
Russians in a quagmire and it was
payback time and they didn't look past
that which was often the problem during
the Cold War about American foreign
policy
it just went this far and didn't go far
enough this novel spans about 40 years
45 what was your approach in that I'll
tell you how it began I was a I had
published another novel with overlooked
pres and Peter Mayer who's the publisher
we were at lunch in New York one day and
he threw out an idea he suggested that I
should I might want to think about doing
a multi-generational saga of the Cold
War and the CIA and the successes and
failures over over a period from the
early days CIA was created in 1948 by
Harry Truman till and let's say the 90s
and the idea immediately attracted me
the the possibilities of humanizing the
CIF putting a human face on the CIA I
think it's something that the fiction
writer can get at perhaps more than a
nonfiction writer to create characters
my characters come out of Yale which was
in the early 50s practically a farm team
for the CIA the famous James Jesus
Angleton was Yale the Yale rowing coach
was a talent scout for the CIA and so my
characters there in the early part of
the book come out of Yale into the CIA
and I wanted to carry them through the
Cold War through the great episodes of
the Cold War and at the same time try to
humanize the CIA and show the the
in-house fighting the the gallantry the
courage and the and the dumbness in
certain areas next called San Diego on
the Republican line for Robert littell
good morning question I have for you is
the
why is it that the United States and not
just the CIA but the FBI do you think
based on your research it have trouble
adapting to the changing environments in
the world I know the FBI once the Cold
War ended focused on street gangs and
prison gangs and was going to try them
under Rico statutes federal Rico
statutes that was one way that they were
trying to adapt to the end of the Cold
War but but I've noticed that the
Congress has trouble with it and most
the federal government has trouble
adapting to the changing environment in
the world I'm more prepared to talk
about the CIA than the FBI but what I
will say is that I think it has a lot to
do with mindset the CIA when it lost its
enemy and which is to say when the
Soviet Union disintegrated and we have
to add a parenthetical idea here that
the CIA didn't predict the
disintegration of the Soviet Union with
the collapse of the Soviet empire but
when it when they lost their enemy the
CIA changed it seems to me it got much
more timid as an organization and its
mindset toward terrorism in the 90s was
more or less this is something to be
controlled but not conquered this wasn't
the way the CIA attacked the KGB during
the Cold War this were the KGB was an
enemy that would be combated and
conquered and beaten terrorism seemed to
be something you just controlled so I
think the main problem in the 90s with
the CIA had to do with mindset the
company is the latest in a series of
books by our author including the
October circle Mother Russia the amateur
the once and future spy an agent in
place to name a few
our next call is West Midlands England
give me a favor turn the volume down I
haven't got any follow your mom go ahead
from the CIA um hasn't it been four
years as we've known in the West that
that the CIA have have been secretly
training mercenaries for terrorism to go
out to all the countries in the world
that they didn't the heard government
said that it didn't like but now I see
on the CNN that they've suddenly opened
up and and and you're not secretive
anymore in that anyway can you tell me
why you go into other countries where
the human rights are chronic and you
don't do it through human rights
yourself and that you're going against
it or it it's not really like the rest
of the world wants it but you decide to
stand on your own and you've always
liked to but this is a new living now
there's a new century and you've got to
come up into this world now it's very
interesting to see what a bad reputation
the CIA has in the world today I don't
share your feeling about what it was
doing the CIA there are you know it made
its mistakes but basically the people
inside it are not murderers and not
killers and they're not trying to bring
down every government in the world that
they don't they don't agree with do you
know that there was there's a United
States law that prohibits the CIA from
assassinating foreign leaders and as far
as I know with the exception of their
their efforts against Castro and there
was one in Africa too they pretty much
stuck to that over the years the CIA
isn't as bad as you think it is they're
not every way of bringing down every
government that crosses the United
States it just doesn't work that way
they really from the nineties on became
an intelligence collection agency more
than an Operations agency because they
closed down all those shops all those
stations all over the
and they were basically listening in on
communication and eavesdropping
collecting information and trying to
analyze the information to see who the
potential enemies were of course they
didn't do the job well enough to prevent
11 September let's go back to the
headlines from over the weekend this is
yesterday's Washington Post on Friday
Robert Hansen 58 years old an FBI agent
for 25 years and spent about 20 years
selling secrets to the Russian
government telling a judge I am shamed
he'll spend the rest of his life in
prison what do we learn from a case like
this I think the first thing we learned
from the sentence why he was sent to
prison for life as opposed to being
subjected to execution was that he's
going to be debriefed for the rest of
his life they are going to stay on this
guy once a week once a month all the
time they want him available for years
and years they want him available so
they can find out what he gave away and
as they put pieces of this puzzle
together they're going to go back to him
I think he's going to be bored to death
in his jail sentence but just by the
debriefings could there be other Robert
Hansen's now in the FBI if history tells
us anything now I wouldn't speak about
the FBI but if history tells us anything
Aldrich turned up in the CIA Hansen
turned up in the FBI we'd be we'd be
naive to think that there aren't others
around the place the the motivation for
betraying your country has to do with
theirs so there are several we know in
Hansen's case that it was money but I
also feel that it had to do with the
fact that he was running the FBI's he
was not he was very much involved in the
FBI's anti-soviet operations and I think
the adrenaline must have been flowing I
think he got a he may have started out
for the money but he must have gotten a
big charge out of being the man who was
supposed to be catching the guy he was
you see what I mean
and the these drops on the bridges and
getting leaving them stuff for the
Russians in garbage sacks and getting
money back and all that this this added
a thrill to a life that looked to be
very humdrum
I think this part of it the
psychological explanation of that there
will be others yeah sorry
that's okay Charlotte North Carolina
independent line for Robert littell good
morning well I'm trying to be ready with
a good question I get lost then I get
down then I get lost and why are you
lost
why am i lost well I just you know I'm
one of these people that communicates
very directly to directly for my own
good that guy called the CIA to offer to
help and that was a big mistake but
anyway I wanted to ask mr. littell is
that correct that's right
okay have you read this it's an old book
it was my father's and I found it in
some a box of my mother had of his and
it it's called the invisible government
no are you familiar with that well it's
it's really old it's from I think it was
published in the early 60s but it's
written by David Weiss and Thomas Ross
and it's about the CIA's what and out
beside the fact that your dad had it oh
because he's talking about the CIA there
today nobody in your own line why do you
remember the book I especially remember
the Bay of Pigs incident and the pilots
that flew the mission being from
Birmingham Alabama that's right which is
where we grew up that's right that was
where I lived and my father was in the
Air Force at the time and my dad had
already passed away but I wondered if he
might have known both man I believe that
he did know I don't know those people
personally by know the story you're
absolutely right the CIA took pilots
from the Air Force they the expression
they used was sheep dip they cheap dip
them I don't know where that expression
even comes from and these were the
pilots who went down and trained the
Cuban pilots so that they could fly the
missions against Castro's Air Force and
eventually try to protect the the
1,600 who will put ashore on the beaches
there was a moment during the Bay of
Pigs when things were going very bad and
Kennedy refused to let he always said
that he would never commit overtly
commit American forces no matter how bad
things got one of the problems in the
Bay of Pigs and I covered this in my
fictional way was that the people to CIA
the man the architect in the CIA was a
gentleman named Bissell and he and
others around him were absolutely
absolutely convinced that if things got
bad enough that Kennedy would relent and
would send in the American planes off
the aircraft carriers which were right
there right off Cuba Kennedy meant what
he said he never did it because he was
thinking of he had a larger horizons he
was thinking of Berlin and what could
happen in Berlin as in retaliation but
to go back to your pilots things got so
bad on the beach that these pilots from
Birmingham who were training the Cubans
in in Latin America at one point they
got in two airplanes and they flew a
mission themselves and when when the
Kennedys learned about this one of the
planes was shot down and the men were
killed Americans were killed and the
Kennedys when they learned about this
they were furious that they had done
this but it shows the deep commitment
that these pilots from Birmingham had to
the Cuban Patriots who were trying to
overthrow Castro Robert littell is a
graduate of Alfred University previously
worked for Newsweek magazine and as we
said earlier has written more than a
dozen novels what's more difficult
writing news accounts for a publication
like Newsweek or writing novels novels
novels are very difficult when you start
out when I when my publisher sent me the
first copy of this book and I opened it
up to the first line it was an amazing
thing for me to reread the first line
and to remember the day I sat down at my
desk because I couldn't see the end of
the tunnel the end of the tunnel in the
printed version is 900 pages away when I
handed it in I'm an old fashioned writer
right
then diskettes or email books in I
delivered a manuscript in a box and it
weighed three kilograms and my French
friends I live in France you know and my
French friends said that littell writes
a kilo a year next call comes to us from
Myrtle Beach South Carolina Democrats
lying good morning Iran sees bed oh yes
good morning um I had a question to ask
mr. littell I believe it was in 1979
that an author named John Marx did a
book called the search Manchurian
Candidate the CIA and mine control
center this book was history of how the
CIA had gotten quite deeply involved
with experimentation with LSD starting
with its discovery from Albert Hofmann
in Switzerland and they essentially
experimented with LSD for years
throughout the 1950s probably well into
the 1960s there was a congressional
hearing I believe was in 77
according to mr. Marx and essentially
the hearing didn't go anywhere and since
then there really hasn't been any
information on this topic and I was
wondering if mr. latel knows anything
about this and what he can say about
this I probably know what you know which
is I remember reading about the the CIA
did get interested in the early days and
did experiments with LSD to see what
effect it would have on people they did
controlled experiments and I even
believe that they subjected people to
these experiments without their
permission I think there was a bit of a
scandal about that a few years ago but I
don't think this this ever went anywhere
in a serious way email from a viewer
by the way our email addresses journal
at c-span or don't forget the hyphen
between the C and the s in your novel do
you reach any conclusions as the role of
the CIA in the modern world i I think I
do I think my own view is that America
certainly needs an intelligence
establishment and especially today the
the world is a very dangerous place
there are a lot of people out there who
want to harm
and we need an intelligence
establishment that can do today what the
CIA did for us in the early 50s which is
to form a barrier between us in them to
to discern who our enemies are what
they're capable ''tis are and just
because there were bad moments in CIA
history the Bay of Pigs is the one we
keep talking about but there were others
I don't think senator Moynihan before he
retired from the Senate suggested that
we disband the CIA and start from
scratch I'm not sure that's what's
needed but I to go back to what I said
to you before I think the first thing
one does after an intelligence failure
of this magnitude I'm talking about 11
September is we have to get outside
people to sit down and take a good long
hard look at the organization to see
where it went wrong
and I also come from a culture a Navy
culture in the sense that I spent four
years in the United States Navy and my
Navy culture taught me that the captain
is responsible for ship there was the
United States destroyer once named the
Hobson and the the captain was asleep in
his sea cabin and a young lieutenant
junior grade or ensign was on the bridge
maneuvering with an aircraft carrier and
by mistake he turned right instead of
left and the Hobson was cut in half I
wonder how many people today remember
that and I think 50 or more sailors were
killed the captain was responsible for
this failure the submarine that came up
but what about a year ago underneath the
Japanese ship as soon as the submarine
got back to port the captain was
relieved of his command now I'm not
suggesting that the director of the CIA
should have been relieved the day after
or the week after or the month after but
I think the director of the CIA who was
there at 9 September who's still there
the director of operations who was there
at 9 September and who's still there I
think eventually these people should be
treated as the captain of a ship is
treated I think they should take
responsibility for the this
incredible intelligence failure why do
you live in France because I'm married
to a French woman that's a good reason
isn't this and this photograph and the
jacket of the book where was it taken
that was taken by my son
I was taken on a bridge in Budapest and
my that was so interesting the idea of
retracing the steps of the Hungarian
Revolution I told you about the
gentleman who showed me around for two
days my son is a painter and he lives in
Prague and I invited him to come down to
share the experience by way of educating
both of us and he was he didn't regret
it at all so he took the picture my son
took the picture on a bridge in Budapest
next call for a Robert Latino author of
the company Bernie Texas Republican line
good morning hey man good to hear y'all
everyday I've been watching you for 10
years just to the trail I'm a former
submarine or myself Atlantic Fleet
Information sheepdip
it's what ranchers do with their cattle
especially sheep they run them through a
combination of water and some agents
that will kill off any ticks and
parasites that might be living on the
Sheep skin in order to keep him healthy
and also in addition to our lady right
horrible lady and gentlemen of the
liberal or labor persuasion who had
called in early from Britain I think it
should be pointed out that naval
proceedings I think of as back around 94
after the fall of the wall it came into
West German government hands
considerable amount of paperwork from
the Stasi the intelligence arm of the
East German government and included the
war plans and the political arrangements
that had already been made between both
East German and Russian in the event of
the ball going up over on the on the
border I'll stop you there we'll get a
response if you want to comment no first
I'm a very appreciative for someone to
explain to me the expression sheepdip
now I added to my knowledge and I agree
with what you was suggesting which is to
contradict the the woman who called in
before
we know who the enemy was they were they
were a serious enemy out there and
you're right about the Stasi papers and
the Stasi plans and it was it was a
killing field it was a tough period of
time there Washington DC independent
line good morning
mr. Hodel I don't read your book yet I
will live in it with a couple questions
first what is your perspective on the
process of spirits work in Russia and
the role of KGB within that process and
second if you'd be kind to give any
contact information that I will drop you
or mine and they have an email address
so public you could use the email
address for this for this program if
you'd like and it would get to me about
you're asking about poutine
he's ex-kgb of course he made his whole
career in the KGB he came up through the
KGB and I think his mentality is a KGB
mentality the KGB has been disbanded not
but not been disbanded it's been given a
facelift so they no longer call it the
KGB but there are Soviet and they're not
Soviet Russian security agencies today
and I don't doubt for a moment that the
Soviet president being from that culture
would not hesitate to use those now give
you one example right away is that he
went into Chechnya if you remember in
the wake of the three explosions that
blew up three apartment houses in Moscow
I don't think there's anybody I know in
Moscow who thinks the Chechens did that
most people great many people think that
it was a put-up job in order to give him
an excuse to go into Chechnya and crack
down which he subsequently did and he's
still there I can add to that that one
of the problems for me in any case about
the President Bush's widespread all
inclusive war on terrorism
is it seems to be giving cover to
anybody in the world who wants to crack
down on legitimate independence
movements poutine is cracking down on
Chechens who want independence they're
not terrorists
the Chinese are cracking down on the we
Gore's who are an Islamic people who
have an independence movement that's
just a footnote to to my poutine comment
in your first note in the book writes
about the creation of the KGB it wasn't
known as that team went through a series
of names from the Cheka at the time of
the revolution on up through the KGB and
what is the deputy director for
operations that's the the head of the
clan the clandestine service of the CIA
in the old days it was called a deputy
director for plans or the nd and the
city and the service was called the
director of plans and at some point they
changed it to operations they just
changed the words next call Fort
Lauderdale Florida
good morning on the Democrats line by
morning I have one question and this
lead back to what the earlier question
were like the question was uh I think
should history be emphasized more in the
public school earlier you said that if
your guest they said that the
administration of John Kennedy started
the big incident I can tell you that
history of red said that the under the
dollars and the administration under
Dwight Eisenhower started the BSA
incident III how can you say that right
now you're distorting history well I'm
not sure what the question is but
history certainly should be taught and
real history should be taught of yes the
old story that those who don't know
history are condemned to repeat it
and there's another quotation which that
each time you repeated it gets more
expensive so I the teaching of history
from my point of view
is one of the principal things that
should go into anybody's education I
remember when I was at the University I
went to a very wonderful school called
Alfred University upstate New York and
my history and political science courses
are still with me and perhaps influenced
me a great deal in my Deraa in the
direction I went toward journalism and
eventually toward writing Republican
line Eureka South Dakota good morning
good morning I happen to know of men but
the name of major Pedro Diaz Lon's
he was the first man who be in charge of
the air force for Castro and he was a
Casarez personal pilot and fought with
Castro all through the Sierra me asked
me extra regime and he told me that he
used to fly to the United States in
these with his plane and the CIA was
loaded up his plane with arms and
ammunition and he told how the CIA
helped Castro overthrow the Batista
regime in Cuban that seems to be the
same scenario we see the countries that
are friendly to us from the Shah of Iran
to to the Niger ideas Nicaragua we see
what's the Somoza down there and you see
the CIA was involved in the overthrow of
virtually governments that are friendly
to the United States and not enemies of
the United States and it seems to be
their regular operation as the CIA has
never really been friendly to this
country it seems their enemies is the
ones they're helping all the time and if
you take a look at bin Laden sir CIA
created this man out so we financed him
and I don't know it's very suspicious
things that that I see for instance are
see one of the CIA directors met with
him two months before this happened he
was in the hospital in Saudi Arabia and
he was in the hospital conferring with
bin Laden I'm not I'm not sure that
particular story has ever been confirmed
I remember seeing that story but I'm not
sure it's been confirmed but let me talk
about Castro and use that as an example
to answer I answer your larger question
you mustn't forget that when Castro came
out of the Sierra masters and
and took over Cuba he came out as a
liberator from a very autocratic regime
the Batista regime and he was viewed by
the Cubans as a liberator and he was
viewed by the United States as a
potential Democrat who could bring
reforms to the island it was only later
perhaps when he was we don't know what
was in Castro's mind from the very
beginning but perhaps because of Che
Guevara and others around him that he
began to began to sound first like a
socialist and then he began to sound
like a communist and then he began to
sound like a client of the Soviet Union
so I don't think you can fault to CIA
for the evolution of Castro who at the
very beginning was simply seen as a hero
and a liberator former President Carter
meeting with Castro tonight it is on
Wednesday yes is Fidel Castro in power
until his death oh I should think so
yes and when he does pass away who takes
over yes I certainly don't know I don't
know next call is from Charleston South
Carolina good morning you're on c-span
our independent line good morning your
program a lot and I enjoy are you
familiar with a book called decent
interval the author by Frank snaps I
believe came out in the late 70s well I
understand it was banned in the United
States initially when it came out to
print and may be incorrect but I
encountered the book in South America
I'm retired
Green break it was on the operation
security detail that went into Jonestown
and trying counter the book yet and I've
just learned your opinion on the book I
remember the book absolutely I think
it's probably incorrect not probably I
think it's incorrect to suggest that any
book has been banned in America this is
a free country
publishers are free to publish what they
want and people are free to buy what
they want I
that book was never banned in America
the the the subject matter of the book
of course being an ex-green beret you
will feel the irony of it that America
at a certain point in his Vietnam policy
was only buying time it wanted from the
title of the book a decent interval to
pass between the time that so they could
get out of Vietnam and say and back out
of it more or less gracefully a lot of
people on both sides were killed during
what we call the decent interval so it's
an it's a moment of irony let me go back
there's a story in this week's edition
of US News and World Report out on these
stands tomorrow by teacher Raghavan who
writes that among the other things that
are being proposed over at the FBI is a
major shift for Robert mullah this is a
quote he wants to consolidate all
terrorism investigations at the bureau's
Washington DC headquarters rather than
allow field offices to take the lead he
will also more than double the resources
for this new division adding 100 new
intelligence analysts to shore up the
FBI's chronic weaknesses with strategy
and Muller also says that he plans to
recruit more Arabic speakers than short
supply right now at the FBI about time
but but the main problem is not going to
be I'm absolutely sure that everybody's
beefing up their anti-terrorism
organizations CIA and the FBI and the
others too the main problem is going to
be sharing information to be organizing
things so that the different
organizations can put on the table what
they know
I mean solving intelligence problems is
like solving a jigsaw puzzle you get
little pieces of information and you put
it together on on a table and you need
to have access to all the information
I'll give you one detail which you
probably are familiar with out of we
know now that the CIA was told was
informed by three foreign intelligence
organizations that bin Laden had
summoned home one of his four wives from
Syria back to Afghanistan I think two or
three weeks before 11 September if this
isn't a piece of a jigsaw puzzle
what is but where were the people who
putting all this on one table and
looking at all the other pieces of
information I think over the years now
as time goes on we're going to see more
and more details what I call pieces of
the jigsaw puzzle coming out and I mean
my whole approach to my book was to look
at the intelligence operations as a big
jigsaw puzzle and that's what's on the
cover of the book if you remember by the
way a previous caller had asked how they
can get a hold of mr. littell if you do
want to email us at journal at c-span
org and we'll put it on the screen you
can do so when we will make sure that he
gets your emails questions or comments
our next call is winston-salem North
Carolina good morning to you on the
Republican line
oh good a good morning this is my first
all I do was your program and I enjoy it
and I just have to turn it on this
morning and mr. littell I've sparked a
memory with me the men that that went
into Cuba the 1600s oh they were
released if I'm not mistaken
edan late 1963 or early 1964 is that
correct yeah it is they eventually the
Kennedy administration I believe traded
tractors and and other things to get
these men out so they were eventually
bought bought out they were brought into
Fort Jackson South Carolina and I was
training in basic training the second
company from top of thought what they
call tank Hill and they bought the
Cubans into some barracks across the
street or road from us and half the the
training company I was in was Puerto
Rican a Puerto Rican National Guard and
these folks did not get along at all
between the these of free Cubans and the
Puerto Ricans I just don't I hadn't
thought about that years and just
listing you that that came back what
happened to the men after they left Fort
Jackson and how long did they stay there
because of course I left my training I I
really don't know in detail I think some
of them were employed by the CIA
eventually but the great mass just went
back to a civilian life and went back to
their lives and many of them came out of
my
me they had lived in Miami they were
recruited in Miami and I suppose they
went back to their their families in
their lives on the Republican line
Detroit good morning I was wondering
what connection that harbored North had
with the CIA in the case of drugs coming
into the country
the fact that we had a plane here in
Detroit that landed and rosy land naval
base south of Detroit it had drugs and
nothing was ever said about it you just
find your research find out anything
about that
no I don't I don't that doesn't ring any
bells with me I know that you're talking
about Casey and Oliver North and the
iran-contra thing we know that they were
selling weapons through they were they
were getting weapons from Israel to Iran
they were taking the money and then
using that money in an unaccountable way
in other words they didn't have to go to
Congress to get money so they have funds
that this was Casey's surely Casey's
invention and Oliver North was a trooper
in in the this.kc operation but about
the drugs I'm not familiar with that at
all
Chicago our independent line good
morning good morning mr. littell I'm a
big fan of yours and congratulations on
your book I have a question what ever
happened to a man named Jimmy Fox he
died suddenly after I guess at the World
Trade Center and the Russian mafia
expell they exposed the Russian mafia in
Brighton Beach in the area of New York
suddenly mr. Foggs died from I believe
food poisoning do you know anything
about that
no but you ought to write a novel about
it it sounds very intriguing I don't
know anything about it no Kenneth Harbor
Maine good morning for Robert littell
yes the lady a while back mentioned
reading a book called the invisible
government do you remember that I
remember the question yeah yes well I'm
my ears pick right up because I'm
reading a book called the invisible
government but he's by a different
author than once he mentioned the one
I'm reading is by dan smoot this
next FBI men and it's all about the the
Council on Foreign Relations and the
trilateral and all of that stuff and the
book is loaded with them kind of people
and so is our government and the news
people like dan Rather and Tom Brokaw
Barbara Walters Marvin and Bernard keV
John Chancellor Walter Cronkite they're
all CFR members and things like then I
don't understand why the people who
don't start finding out about things
like this all they have to do is go to
that library I'll call the job their
society they've got all kind of
information on these kind of people is
he suggesting that all these people are
CIA members well he's still on the line
I are you okay I heard CIA I can't say
anything about that except that if you
think there's a great conspiracy going
on I couldn't agree with you less you're
talking about very distinguished
American news people and I don't see a
great conspiracy going on except to
bring the news to the American people
what's the message from the company I
don't think it's a book with a message I
think it's a book it's a historical
novel and it's a book about the Cold War
and history and I don't think it has any
message it's supposed to be it pretends
to be you know graham greene's famous
expression that he wrote entertainments
the first thing a novelist does is he
wants to tell the story and entertain
his readers after that if there's a
layers bedrock of real history and real
events and real characters because I
interlace my fictional characters with
many of the legendary CIA people and
that's a bonus from the book robert
littell thank you for being with us
thank you is a great pleasure some
scheduling information for you first of
all check out book TV on c-span - all
day Saturday and Sunday 48 hours of
nonfiction books this afternoon at one
o'clock Eastern Time here on c-span we
will show you a speech by King Abdullah
of Jordan he talks about the Mideast
peace process his remarks at Rice
University in Houston he was in
Washington earlier in the week you can
see that again today at 1:00 Eastern ten
o'clock for those of you in the West
Coast and our American writers to series
continues with ayan ran as we look at
the
examination of the depression and the
war years with her book afternoon at
3:00 Eastern Time 12 o'clock for those
of you on the west coast live from
Hollywood California more information on
our American writer series part two as
we travel through the 20th century by
logging on to American writers org
tomorrow morning on c-span Washington
Journal among our guest Laura Ingraham
from Westwood one radio and John Moyers
of Tom Paine dot-com the publisher of
that online website it is Mother's Day
to moms out there including my own happy
Mother's Day enjoy the rest of your
weekend